we mentioned Winston Churchill with his
signature cane drinking scotch whiskey
and puffing on a Cuban cigar his mouth
is down turned and his voice is gruff
and his words pointed this is the image
that Hollywood portrays but it isn't
mere character of the flesh-and-blood
version so who was Winston Churchill in
Britain's darkest hour Churchill led his
country from the brink of Nazi conquest
by forging an alliance with the US and
Russia
he had many critics and made mistakes on
a grand scale yet above all possessed an
unwavering belief in his own power to
his beloved country he offered his blood
toil tears and sweat behind the
political figure was a family man a man
of literary distinction an artist a
great lover of pets and a tinkerer yes
Winston Churchill had many hobbies today
on biographic Swee paints the complex
picture of the lion so Winston Churchill
[Music]
so incident churchill was born on
November 30th 1874 into the upper
echelon of British society
his father was Lord Randolph Henry
Spencer Churchill a prominent politician
in the third son of the seventh Duke of
Marlborough Churchill's mother Jennie
Jerome was an American beauty and
socialite the daughter of a wealthy New
York stockbroker and financier the
glamorous couple would seem like a match
made in heaven but they lived mostly
apart and carried on separate lives they
also couldn't really be bothered with
the young Winston the very privileged of
his pedigree didn't afford in the kind
of love and affection that he sought
from his parents
sadly throughout his life both father
and mother were distant and neglectful
fortunately vote for the young Winston
there was one adult in his life who
provided emotional support and acted
like a mother figure
Churchill's nanny Elizabeth Everest
women as Winston called her after a
failed attempts at saying women as a
child
was hired to care for Winston when he
was one month old she would remain his
only real friends and confidants
throughout his childhood when she passed
away Churchill said of her she had been
my dearest and most intimate friend
during the whole 20 years I had lived I
shall never know such a friend again
Winston was just seven years old when he
was sent away to some Georges school at
Ascot avoiding school it was not
uncommon for school children in
upper-class society to be sent away but
his mother dropped him off at Paddington
Station alone to catch the train at his
first school Winston was bullied and
bruised by the headmaster who commonly
birched the students a form of corporal
punishment that involved striking the
bare bottoms of boys the misbehaved with
visible scars on Winston from the
beatings and pleas from his loving nanny
his parents withdrew him and placed him
in the Brighton school in 1882 Winston
escaped the brutality of his first
school but not the lessons of Brighton
which he despised Winston hated the
regiments and was rebellious his poor
academic scores and speech impediments a
list made Winston and easy targets and
subject to ridicule in 1888 Winston
enrolled at the Harris school but with
abysmal entry scores he placed at the
bottom of his class at Harry Winston
excelled in the subjects that interested
him including English and history he
also demonstrated a prowess for the
sport of fencing winning the public
schools fencing championship yet the few
bright spots were ever shadowed by deep
sadness
recalled in retrospect those years
formed not only the least agreeable but
also the only barren and unhappy part of
my life
Winston Churchill nearly died from the
self-imposed act of bravado at the age
of 18 when he jumped off a bridge he
would later India three days of
unconsciousness a ruptured kidney and
three months in bet it happens when the
teenager was playing chase with his
twelve-year-old brother Jack and his 14
year old cousin while vacationing at
their answer state according to
Churchill in his 1930 memoir he was
trapped on a rustic bridge with brother
at one end and cousin at the other
rather than be captured
Churchill left from the bridge aiming
for a pine tree to slide down he greatly
misjudged the distance and fell the full
height onto hard grounds Churchill was
extremely lucky to survive but it
wouldn't be his last brush with death
indeed during his life Churchill was
prone to accidents including crashing a
plane while learning to fly nearly
drowning in a lake
falling several times from horses and
getting hit by a car while trying to
cross New York's Fifth Avenue due to his
poor grades at Harrow it appeared
Churchill's only chance at a career was
through the army it took Churchill three
attempts to pass the exam for the raw
Military College at Sandhurst Churchill
described taking the last portion of the
exam and leaving it completely blank
except for his name and number a blot
and several smudges his father had
wanted him to be in the infantry but his
scores were only good enough for the
cavalry the new training at Sandhurst
excited Churchill and over the next 18
months
Churchill thrived he recalled I was no
longer handicapped by past neglect of
Latin French or mathematics we now had
to learn fresh things and we all started
equal tactics fortification topography
military law and military fortification
forms the entire curriculum in addition
were drill gymnastics and riding
Churchill finished 20th out of 130 in
his graduating class Churchill craved
action and showed no fear on the battle
fronts Churchill knew that he was
destined for great things and he had to
prove it to the world and war provided
the perfect opportunity to do so
Churchill served in the British Army
there only for a short time from 1895 to
and during the same time wrote military
reports for newspapers as well as two
books the story of the Malakand field
force and the river war in 1899
Churchill stepped into politics
to win election to the House of Commons
but he failed without hesitation he
traveled to South Africa to cover
Britain's war with the buzz as a London
post war correspondent at the age of 25
Churchill arrived in Cape Town with 18
bottles of scotch and a guarantee of a
hundred and fifty thousand dollars in
today's money for a four month
assignment one day Churchill admitted to
his brother
there is no ambition I cherish so keenly
has to gain a reputation for personal
courage he would soon get the chance to
earn that reputation in South Africa
while covering the war Churchill was
aboard a train with soldiers sent on a
reconnaissance mission
the train was suddenly ambushed by the
enemy and Churchill immediately sprung
into action under fire he acted like a
decorated general and ordered the
soldiers with him to flee to safety most
of them did that Churchill was captured
as a prisoner of war and sent Pretoria
Churchill's conditions in captivity they
could have been worse the birds allowed
prisoners to buy cigarettes beer and
newspapers the Churchill hated every
moment of it feeling the opportunity for
glory slipping him by one night with no
real plan of how to make it out of 300
miles of enemy territory
he made a daring escape a massive
manhunt ensued and the fugitive
Churchill was wanted dead or alive he
avoided capture traveling at night and
drinking water from streams and when he
could go no further he took a chance by
knocking on a stranger's door on the
other side he knew not whether there'd
be Friend or Foe saved by pure chance or
fate it was an Englishman who answered I
felt like a drowning man pulled out of
the water Churchill would recall the
Englishman was John Howard a coal mine
manager who hid Churchill in a
pitch-black mine before he could be
smuggled to safety during this time in
the mine
rats which actual say any company in
Britain the story of an English Lords
son escaping prison camp and humiliating
the burrs was a boost to the nation he
became a hero and a celebrity pretty
much overnight
you
with a hero's welcome and newfound
popularity Churchill ran for office and
this time in 1900 he was elected as a
member of parliament in the House of
Commons this was the start of a 55 year
long political career with the highest
of the highest and the lowest of the
lows Churchill once said politics is
almost as exciting as war and quite as
dangerous in war you can only be called
once but in politics many times
Churchill was a conservative when he
first stepped into the House of Commons
that he repeatedly clashed with his
party on a number of issues free trade
was crucial in his mind and in 1904 it
was his party's support of tariffs that
made Church or cross the floor to the
opposing liberal side it infuriated his
fellow conservatives but it proved to be
great timing
the Liberals took control soon after as
a newfound liberal Churchill concerned
himself with social reforms and laid the
groundwork for the post-war welfare
state
Churchill again ratted or switched sides
back to the Conservative Party in 1925
the flippant politician was highly
criticized for the moves and he was seen
as an untrustworthy opportunist
Churchill's greatest political failure
though the one nearly ruined his career
came in 1915 World War one was at a
stalemate along the western France with
Allied troops engaged in deadly trench
warfare anxious to end it
Britain's War Cabinet authorized a bold
military attack the mastermind of the 40
year old First Lord of the Admiralty
Winston Churchill the campaign would
send troops over 1,000 miles to the east
establishing a second front to
eventually seize Constantinople and take
control of the sea route from Europe to
Russia the plan involved a naval attack
through the Dardanelles Strait and then
a land invasion on the gallop Eenie
Peninsula in modern-day Turkey lack of
intelligence incompetence and hesitation
by military commanders created the
perfect storm and the campaign went
horribly wrong half of the ships were
lost and a bloodbath on the shores
lasted nine months in all 45,000 Allied
troops in 65,000 Turkish troops lost
their lives right or wrong
Churchill bore the brunt of this failure
and it forced his resignation from
politics for a while
Churchill he used this opportunity to
return to the war front to gallop any
campaign haunted Churchill for decades
remember the Dardanelles
was a favorite taunt from political
opponents throughout his career a second
controversy would plague Churchill for a
decade and send him into political exile
a period known as the wilderness yes in
1929 a debate erupted over
self-governance in India which was at
the time under British rule Churchill
was no doubt an imperialist and was
vehemently opposed he also had no love
for Gandhi he saw him as a threat to the
British Empire and went so far as to say
Gandhi should not be released on the
account of a mere threat of fasting we
should be rid of a bad man and an enemy
of the Empire if he died except for the
most right-wing of conservatives
Churchill was alone in his position much
has been written about Winston Churchill
The Statesman but what was the bulldog
like at home who was he to his friends
and his family when Clementine hozier
met the 29 year old Winston in 1904 to
dance she wasn't impressed he didn't ask
her to dance just stared and never
uttered one word and was very gauche
four years later they would meet again
at a dinner party and this time a
remnants blossomed the couple married in
1908 and would endure 57 years together
until Winston's death at the age of 90
even though clementines politics
differed from Winston's she was fiercely
supportive and maid standing by her man
and number one priority she quietly
advised him and was the only person who
could reprimand his behavior Clementine
once said she would have loved to have
been a statesman in our own right if she
had been born with trousers rather than
petticoats Winston was overbearing and
temperamental at times but he was always
transparent in his love for his wife
proudly boasting to Roosevelt I tell
penny everything on occasion the couple
would fight though money was a constant
warrior for Clementine who was born into
the aristocracy but wound up penniless
in her youth
Winston overspent enjoyed gambling and
was in and out of debt during one
particularly passionate dispute
Clementine famously threw a plate of
spinach at her husband's but it missed
she also never really forgave him for
buying the family home and money this
Chartwell doing so on the sly when she
was laid up from giving birth the couple
had five children but only four would
survive into adulthood
their third child marigold died at the
age of two and a half from septicemia
which is an infection of the blood
unfort
for her this is a condition that
modern-day antibiotics would easily cure
Clementine shrieked in anger like an
animal in mortal pain upon her
daughter's death one year later the
Churchill's fourth child Mary was born
Winston he was delighted to have the
nursery in use again
Churchill's duties as a statesman often
took him away from home but he was
devoted to his family determined to be
different from his own parents who were
distant and Cole's whenever he could he
doted upon his children he build them a
treehouse of the family home and used
his skills as a bricklayer to construct
a little summer house for Mary over 40
years at Chartwell Churchill proudly
improved the property by using his own
hands building ponds structures and
bridges the Churchill's had a multitude
of pets domestic and exotic Churchill
was an animal lover his whole life as a
teen in 1891 he even sold his bicycle to
buy a bulldog named dodo at the family
home both cats and dogs as well as pigs
fish butterfly sheeps horses and black
swans there was even a parrot called
Charlie who it was rumoured to Churchill
talk to spork obscenities against Hitler
and the Nazis though this has proven and
is most likely a myth when not enamored
with politics and taxing as the savior
of his country Churchill was writing
painting playing polo laying bricks at
the family home or vacationing with
friends in Monte Carlo or some other
exotic locale
we shall fight on the beaches we shall
fight on the landing grounds we shall
fight in the fields and in the streets
we shall fight in the Hills we shall
never surrender if it wasn't for Hitler
in the Nazis Churchill may never have
become Britain's Prime Minister after
losing his cabinet position in 1929 many
believed Churchill's political career
was over even though he was out of
politics he was not out of the public
eye he continued to write books speeches
and newspaper articles and warned of the
dangers of Hitler from his home in
Kansas the predictions of the growing
Nazi power and the quest for domination
was coming true he later wrote in his
memoirs my warnings over the last six
years had been so numerous so detailed
and were now so terribly vindicated that
no one could gainsay me at the war's
outbreak then Prime Minister Neville
Chamberlain brought Church or back into
the fray as Britain's First Lord of the
Admiralty the same position that he held
during the First World War
Chamberlain had tried and failed to
strike a peace deal with Hitler and he
showed himself to be incapable of
turning the rapid tide of fascism
Chamberlain had also lost the support of
his cabinet when British troops couldn't
prevent the occupation of Norway in 1940
Chamberlain resigned and Churchill took
over as Prime Minister at the darkest
hour that same day May the 10th Hitler
invaded Holland Belgium and the
Netherlands Churchill was a brilliant
orator thanks to his mastery of words he
inspired his countrymen to fight and
some of his speeches during the early
days of the war are some of the most
powerful in the English language victory
was the only option he never even
considered defeat even when the outlook
looked most grim when France fell to the
Nazis Britain was alone in its fight
Churchill knew his island nation could
not win the war alone he would need the
United States and when Germany invaded
Russia Churchill saw an opportunity to
forge an unlikely alliance Britain came
to Stalin's end and Churchill defended
the decision during this desperate time
saying no one has been a more consistent
opponent of communism for the last 25
years
I will unsay no word I have spoken about
it but all this fades away before the
spectacle which is now unfolding the
past with its crimes its follies its
tragedies flashes away the Russian
danger is therefore our danger and the
danger of the United States just
the cause of any Russian fighting for
half and house is the cause of free men
and free peoples in every quarter of the
globe to forge the big-three alliance
Churchill cultivated a friendship with
the American President Franklin D
Roosevelt this was something that would
convince him to join the war effort he
invited himself to the White House and
arrived two weeks after the bombing of
Pearl Harbor the Prime Minister stayed
three weeks through Christmas and well
past his welcome in Eleanor Roosevelt
sighs but it was absolutely critical to
solidifying their alliance and winning
over the Americans the two bonded over
daily lunches and late-night
strategizing by the time he left
FDR founds that he missed his friends
and sent a note to Churchill in London
which read it is fun to be in the same
decade with you with the Americans now
in the war and the Russians fighting on
the side of the Allies Hitler's armies
were pushed back and victory was
declared on May the 8th 1945 in Europe
three months later in the East Japan
surrendered marking the end of World War
two in a surprise that very same year
Churchill did not win re-election
following the war Churchill continued to
influence world affairs
he gave his speech on the Iron Curtain
about the USSR threat and was strongly
in favor of Britain's independence from
the European Coal and Steel community
which was set up after the war to
neutralize European competition for
natural resources Churchill actually
served as Prime Minister again in 1951
and resigns at the age of 80 it was at
this time that he was in deteriorating
health Churchill was intense on leaving
his mark on history not just through
clamoring for Fame and power or placing
himself at the center of the action
indeed he would write his own story and
solidify a favorable view to be passed
through the ages at the end of World War
two Churchill wrote his best-selling
series second world war and won the
Nobel Prize in Literature in 1953 in
that same year he was knighted by Queen
Elizabeth the second in 1965 after
suffering a stroke two weeks earlier
Winston Churchill passed from this life
until the next it seems the whole world
felt the loss and reporters remarked
that it was the end of an era the Queen
saw to it that Churchill's funeral was
the grandest of any commoner since 1852
which was on a scale befitting his
position in history his body lay in
state in Westminster Hall for three days
and nights and no fewer than three
hundred and twenty thousand people filed
past to pay their respects and as we
move towards the end of this video let
me mention something interesting ten
years ago a fifth of all British
teenagers poles believed Churchill to be
a fictional character his Legend indeed
may seem larger than life and knowing
the man apart from his greatest moment
on the world stage is hard to grasp to
say he was complex and contradictory is
an understatement
we know he held himself in the highest
regard but Churchill also suffered in
the depths of depression he referred to
it as his black dog his stubbornness
courage grid since brilliance with words
made him indispensable and his legacy is
one that will live on and inspire the
good fight and no doubt Churchill will
continue to be judged and analyzed
through the ages for his failed
decisions and unpopular attitudes he was
a product of the time with an impossible
job statesmen are not called upon to
settle easy questions these often settle
themselves it is where the balance
Quivers and the proportions are veiled
in mist that the opportunity for world
saving decisions presents itself so I
really hope you enjoyed that episode of
biographic s-- if you did there's a
couple of things you could do right now
one is hit that like button below also
if you want more stuff like this we put
out brand new videos every Monday and
every Thursday so hit that subscribe
button below and subscribe button
doesn't do what it used to on YouTube if
you actually want to get a notification
about these videos please do hit that
Bell button next to the subscribe button
and that'll send you a notification
every time every Monday and Thursday we
won't put out a new video also if you
want to watch something else right now
stuff from the archive over there on the
right and as always thank you for
watching